so let's do a quick recap the last two
movies in 90 seconds or less
you ready the bass run is about a group
of boys who are trapped in designated
area called the glade surrounded by
giant pools and surviving on supply
center by the boxes once a month by a
cryptic entity called wicked is good
and in the maze of these things called
grievers once a month a new boy comes
this month it happens to be this kid
named Thomas any select few runners are
allowed beyond the walls but Thomas
breaks that roll to save their leader
Alby and me now by killing a griever
Thomas goes on Mission Impossible style
on Bolton who saves the three of them
suddenly a cow named Theresa comes up in
the books and recognizes Thomas I know
Thomas Thomas like I know you and a
struggle for power and shoes when the
second and come on Newt designates
Thomas a runner
Thomas is a revelation that wicked is
using him as a test subject and that he
used to actually work for them boston's
and he leads a group through the maze
where they uncover a secret laboratory
and then have dr. Ava page wickets
director of operations and a deadly
virus called a flare that it's ravish
the earth
none from Ava the experiment was a
success survivors are now entering phase
two the Scorch Trials
so into the scores Charles we are out in
his designated area called the scorch
where this is fires called the flare and
things turning in Craig's the reading
Gladers
Thomas neutrino Theresa friar Peter
Winston taken to a wicked facility run
by mr. Jansen it looks like he's on Game
of Thrones and who was supposed to
protecting them from Krank zombies
created by the flare virus but is
actually just a way for wicked to
continue their experiments but some the
immune kiss and find a cure for
themselves Thomas meets a survivor eros
with the group they escape to the
outside world
scourge where they befriend Brenda and
Jorge Jorge looks like he's on Breaking
Bad I'm sorry oh mama looks like you're
tagged none of the resistance called it
right on thank you thanks that you know
a page comes in Theresa portrays us
because she called a pager and his cell
phone was like Adam to meet always
captured oh no next thing you know they
say Garrett
Thomas and the remaining bladers out to
join forces with a right arm rescue
their friends would topple wicked finds
that cure
[Music]
you